we always hear about that artistic
struggle where someone you know grew up
in an orphanage and they overcame you
know terrible hardship and then they
were able to take all that sort of angst
and turn it into roles but does someone
have to go through all that can someone
be from a great upbringing their parents
paid for their college education and
then they can somehow turn that on and
tap into that dark side that they don't
want to admit within a nice party of
people that they have but everybody does
have it do you have to struggle i I
don't know anybody who hasn't been
through pain I mean I know very wealthy
people and they're some of my friends of
mine but the size of the house and the
model of the car and the clothes that
you wear to mask your humanity and your
vulnerability is nothing real I mean you
can go into many many mansions and meet
misery in the face I mean so an actor
who's grown up in privilege it doesn't
mean that his father did not abuse him
it does not mean his mother was not
insane it means the the appearance of
perfection was there right does that
make any sense yeah fascinating so going
back to the most talented actors making
making it in Hollywood you've mentioned
many factors what does work ethic play
into that and what if somebody has so
many things especially work ethic but
it's somehow lacking and something else
and never makes it I mean is work ethic
Izzy can you fail at having a great work
ethic and really try to make it in this
business well I think what you're
talking about you know having a great
worth a work ethic and still failing
that applies to any business I mean you
can know everything with if you don't
know anybody whatever you know becomes
insignificant because you have no path
to realize your dream you have to have a
mission a a path some people are very
lucky and very fortunate they exchange
sexual favors or whatever it is and they
get ahead so whatever no pun intended
but the fact of the matter is is that
just being talented only it's kind of
and this is my opinion a naive thought
in terms of making it because it's cost
your business and if you are have a nice
face and a nice body that's okay but you
have no understanding of the industry
you can be used for some period of time
but the time that you're being used
you should be leveraging you know a
friend of my scissors and I believe it
now you know he says this is the pimping
whole game you know he says as long as
you're not the one wearing the fishnets
and pumps all the time it's a good game
to be in as long as you pimpin sometimes
you're just I don't look good in
fishnets and pumps that's one of the
things that I have probably you know
it's you don't want to see that picture
but the fact of the matter is is that
but the agents and the managers go out
there and they're fishnets and pumps and
provide something for you are you paying
your percentage to so talent is one
aspect of it but the business of making
sure that your talent talent is
leveraged to your benefit also you
should own something you should own your
own content at some point right now
listen these guys two guys made a
feature film with two cell phones
so you're waiting to be discovered
you